welcome to solving a quadratic by
factoring let's start doing some
problems so let's say I had a function f
of X is equal to x squared plus 6x plus
8
now if I were to graph f of X the graph
is going to look something like this I
don't know exactly what it's going to
look like but it's going to be a
parabola and it's going to intersect the
x axis at a couple of points here and
here and what we're going to try to do
is determine what those two points are
so first of all when a function
intersects the x axis that means f of X
is equal to 0 because this is the f of X
axis similar to the y axis so here f of
X is 0 so in order to solve this
equation we set f of X to 0 and we get x
squared plus 6x plus 8 is equal to 0 now
this might look like you could solve it
pretty easily but that x squared term
kind of messes things up and you could
try it out on your for yourself so what
we're going to do is factor this and
we're going to say that x squared plus
6x plus 8 that this can be written as X
plus something times X plus something
and will still equal that so that's
equal 0 now in this presentation I'm
going to show you the the systematic or
you could say the mechanical way of
doing this so I'm gonna give you another
presentation on on why this works and
and you might want to just multiply out
the answers we get and multi multiply
out the expressions and see why it works
and the method we're going to use is we
look at the coefficient on this X term
and 6 and we say what two numbers will
add up to 6 and when those same two
numbers are multiplied you're going to
get 8 well let's just think about the
factors of 8 the factors of 8 are 1 2 4
& 8
well 1 times 8 is 8 but 1 plus 8 is 9 so
that doesn't work
2 times 4 is 8 and 2 plus 4 is 6 so that
works so we could just say X plus 2 and
X plus 4 is equal to 0 now if two
expressions or two numbers times each
other equals zero that means that one of
those two numbers or both of them must
equal zero so we have two now we could
say that X plus 2 equals 0 or or and X
plus 4 is equal to 0 well this is just a
very simple equation we subtract 2 from
both sides and we get x equals negative
2 and here we get x equals minus 4 and
if we substitute either of these into
the original equation we'll see that it
works
minus 2 so let's let's just try it with
minus 2 and now leave it - 4 up to you
so minus 2 squared plus 6 times minus 2
plus 8 minus 2 squared that's a squared
is 4 minus 12 6 times minus 2 plus 8 and
sure enough that equals 0 and if you did
the same thing with negative 4 you'd
also see that that works and you might
be saying wow this is interesting this
is an equation that has two solutions
well if you think about it makes sense
because the graph of f of X is
intersecting the x axis in two different
places let's do another problem
let's say I had f of X is equal to 2x
squared plus 20x plus 50 so if we want
to figure out where two intersects the
x-axis we just set f of X equal to zero
and I'll just swap the left and right
left and right sides of the equation and
I get 2x squared plus 20x plus 50 equals
zero now what's a little different this
time from last time is here the
coefficient of x squared is actually two
instead of a one and I like it to be a 1
so let's divide the whole equation both
the left and right sides by 2 and I get
x squared plus 10x plus 25 equals zero
so all I did is I multiplied one half
times this is the same thing as dividing
by two and did times one half and of
course zero times one half is 0 now
we're ready to do what we did before and
you might want to pause it and try it
yourself we're going to say X plus
something times X plus something is
equal to zero and those two nuts some
things they should add up to 10 and when
you multiply them they should be 25
let's think about the factors of 25 you
have 1 5 and 25 well 1 times 25 is 25
but 1 plus 25 is 26 not 10 5 times 5 is
25 and 5 plus 5 is 10 so 5 actually
works so actually turns out that both of
these numbers are 5 and so you get X
plus 5 equals 0 or X plus 5 equals 0 so
you just have to really write at once so
you get x equals negative 5 so how do we
think about this graphically I just told
you that these equations can intersect
the x-axis in two places but this one
only has one solution
well this solution would look like this
if this is x equals negative five we'd
have a parabola that just touches right
there and then it comes back up so
instead of intersecting two places it
only intersects right there at x equals
negative five and now as an exercise
just to prove to you that I'm not I'm
not teaching you incorrectly let's let's
multiply X plus 5 times X plus 5 just to
show you that it equals what it should
equal so we just say that this is the
same thing as x times X plus 5 plus 5
times X plus 5 X 10 so you get x squared
plus 5 X plus 5 X plus 25 and that's x
squared plus 10x plus 25 so it equals
what we said it should equal and I'm
going to once again do another module
where I explain this a little bit more
let's do one more problem and this one
I'm just going to cut to the chase let's
just solve x squared minus X minus 30 is
equal to zero
once again two numbers when we add them
they equal what's the coefficient here
it's negative one so we can even say we
could say those two numbers or a plus B
equals minus one and a times B will
equal minus 30 well let's just think
about what all the factors are of 30
there's one two three five six ten
fifteen and thirty well something
interesting is happening this time
though since a times B is negative
thirty one of these numbers have to be
negative they both can't be negative
because if if they're both negative then
this would be a positive 30 so eight
times B is negative thirty so it's
actually we're going to say two of these
factors the difference between them
should be negative one well if we look
at all of these all these numbers
obviously when you pair them up they
multiply out to 30 but the only ones
that have a difference of one is five
and six and since it's a negative one
it's going to be and I know I'm going
very fast to this and I'll do more
example problems so it'll be X minus 6
times X plus 5 is equal to 0 so how did
I think about that negative 6 times 5 is
negative 30 negative 6 plus 5 is
negative 1 so it works out and the more
and more you do these practices I know
it seems a little confusing right now
it'll make a lot more sense so you get x
equals 6 or x equals negative 5 I think
at this point you're ready to try some
some solving quadratics by factoring and
I'll do a couple more modules as soon as
you get some more practice problems have
fun